[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savoie annecy
lucas vient peut être près de moi parce
que là je suis venu pour un thalassa la
recette très simple ce avec des épreuves
de rapidité
celui qui arrive dernier à une panne à
la première à nas pour celui qui perdra
ses amants à tarte à la crème vous avez
devant vous une banane chacun ramon
signal voulait plus hachée et vous la
mangez entièrement et moi-même j'adore
les malades dépendants de la plus
radicale
non seulement c'est manger bon et c'est
bon
la deuxième tana s'appelle fixation
béton il va falloir se défier des
lunettes sur le visage avec du rouge à
lèvres 2 1 on est bas merde pas il s'est
cassé et tous les marseillais vous fait
un shampoing totale avec le gel grêle
joue pas je vais t'aider un peu aux noms
amicaux
là bas tu sais quoi
si tu look ou même seulement les cheveux
ça va pas marcher pour le coiffe aussi
la barre et les sourcils son frère son
plat non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression d'y a rien de chimique
comme argument vengeance on le sait deux
embarquent michaël youn jour est tout et
c'est fukushima dans ma bouche la donne
et boire la voudrait voir vraiment où le
ratio n'est jamais de la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible ça ne tient pas
debout bonsoir vous êtes championne de
booty shake
merci à petit alors allez j on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
ça fait mal pour les producteurs les
gones à droite sur 10 ha oui ah oui on a
chacun
mais son tarif
[Applaudissements]
parler tout prix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
[Musique]